百七十八ページでバーワルート二つ書いてますね
女性男性の形質ですね
で ただそれだけ ある色受想行識の塊と
またある色受想行識の塊二つあって
前にある色受想行識の塊の中で
識の中に女性と女性という識が入っていて
こちらは男性という識が入っていて
これほんのちょっとの働きだけなんですね
あるちょっとその物体が区別する
ちょっとした違う働きなんです
その働きによって これは女性です
これは男性ですと言っちゃうんですね
だから女性です 男性ですというラベリング作るためには
ほんのちょっとの働きもそこであるんですね
そうやってヴィッジャマーネーナアヴィッジャマーナパンニャーって見える実際にあるものから実際ないものは作る
そこに実際にないものから実際にあるものを作るということなんですが
こちらの例えは こちら女性の声とか
例えば鳥の声といったところで
鳥というものは存在しないんです
声というものはあるエネルギーなんです
音を出さない ですから鳥の声とかね
と言った途端 そこはないものからあるものを示しているんですね
ないものからある まあこの声に例えば
ピアノを聞こえてますと言ったところで
ピアノが聞こえるわけじゃないし
ピアノというものは実際には存在しない
小さいカフはあるんだけど
ピアノっていうのはないんですね
だからピアノは聞こえますと言ったところで
本当に聞こえるのは音という色なんですね
ですから音という色にピアノというだけで
だからある 何て言いますか
存在しないラベルで存在するもの考えているんですね
存在しないラベリングをするんです
存在するもの それはアヴィッジャマーネーナヴィッジャマーナパンニャーって
実際にないもので実際にあるものネーミングする
だから普通の言語はそういうことを
例えばピアノ ピアノが聞こえてきますよというのは決して無意味な言葉じゃないんです
誰もあんた変なことを聞いてるんだと全然言わないんですね
ピアノの音がと言ったところで正しいんだけど
それでも音を消してピアノだけでもいいんです
そうやってこの言葉使ってるんですね
次にはヴィッジャマーネーナヴィッジャマーナパンニャー
まあ本当にあるものにネーミングすること
例えば目にあるチャックヴィンヤーナ眼識といえば目の感覚ですね
目に何か触れたら目で何か感覚が起こるんです
それは眼識という 耳に音が触れたら感覚生まれるんですね
それには耳識ですか と呼ぶんですね
鼻に何か触れたら感覚が起こるんです
それを鼻識と呼ぶんです
そうやってこの六識やら
そうやって実際に起こってくる感覚に
またそれなりのネーミングをする
そうやってネーミングの世界はあります
あまりにもそこら辺はね
簡単でやりますし 説明しようとするとかなりの哲学的な世界になっちゃいますからね
できるだけ簡単にしようかなと思ったんですから
もし分からなかったら
このそこら辺は読みになってみてください
そんなに難しいことではないんです
ネーミングする世界のこと
仏教の違うところっていうのは
ちゃんと区別を知ってほしいんですね
この区別を知っていると
よく頭がよく理解できるんですね
誤魔化しなくて 神話とかね
そういう これあの どういう日本の神話なんですか
あのヨーロッパの神話ではイソップでも出てきますけどね
貧しい人が山に行って
この薪を 木からカットして売ってなんとか生活していて
そこである日自分の斧を持って 1本の斧しか持ってない
それもあんまりいいものじゃないんですね
貧しいんだから それで木を切っている時で
手を滑っちゃって そこに池にボーンと落ちちゃうでしょ
そこでその人の全部もう終わり
人生はもう仕事はできなくなっちゃう
食べるものなくなっちゃって
終わっちゃいますよ その人はもうどうしようかと泣いてる
そこで池の中からある神様というか
あるもう池の神様が出てきて
なんで泣いてるんですか？私のもうもう全部もう人生がこれで終わってしまう
食べるものはもうこれきりで生きていられなくなっちゃった
斧が池に落ちた だから自分の人生と同じものを生き方
命そのものでしたから
それで神様はわかりましたと言って
金のお斧を持ってきて
これですかと で 違いますと
で また銀のお斧を持ってきて
これですと で 違いますと
それで自分の本物のお斧を持ってきて
これです はい それですと
ありがとうございますと
で もらっちゃうと そういうストーリーがあるでしょうに
そこはこの そういうストーリーではあまり誤解しません
僕は誤解しやすいストーリーを考えちゃったのは思い出したくはそうしたんだけど
なかなか思い出せなくて
あの だからストーリーはそれだけで十分でしょう
それで必ずしも池やら山やらに木やら
そういうところには精霊が宿っていて
で なんとかなんとかしてくれると思ったら
まあ大間違いで そういう人で二番目もあるでしょ
そこで怪しげな人がいて
もうひどい目にあると
だからストーリー作った時点ではきちんと作ってるんです
これは一般人が何の教育もない人々が作ってるストーリーなんです
きちんとこの そのもう一つの二番目もちゃんとできてあって
だからそれはそれだけで十分でしょうし
その上で考えて やっぱり人類は昔からもう精霊あったことは信仰していたんでしょうと
だからやたらに否定できませんと
いうところでむちゃくちゃでしょうに
やたらに精霊 悪霊ないと
そんな言ったらダメですよと
見なさいと その連中がおかしいんです
その言葉と言葉の意味と
そのそこら辺理解してないんですね
だから私が言うのは この一般の人々を使っているレベルで使っちゃえばあまり問題ないんです
故に 悪霊 心霊がいるんだというところはおかしいんですね
そこで論理的に成り立たないところは
まあ一応あのもう精霊に頼んでやってもらうと
それだけのことで もう池に落ちてしまったあの人はね
おじいちゃんが死ぬしか道がないでしょうに
だから死なすわけにはいきませんよ
真面目に仕事をして生きてる人が
そこはポイントなんです
真面目にコツコツと頑張って汗を流して仕事する人は死なすわけにはいきませんね
それでいいという道徳書いてるんです
たまたまひどい目に遭っても
あなたは誰にも迷惑をかけないでしっかり生きてるんだから
あなたこそすごいと という道徳を言ってるだけのことだから
それはもう精霊が出てこないとストーリー成り立たなくて人が死んじゃうんです
だからそこでもう神様が出てきて
もうだから昔の人々はそういうストーリー聞いて
ああ よかったと おじいちゃんが助けられてよかったと
幸せになってよかった
それで終わるだけ でも我々現代人はどうですかね
一生懸命言って拝んだり
じゃあ私を助けてくれと
あのストーリーで言うのは頑張りなさい
それだけのことなんです
だからこの古いストーリーというのはかなり論理的で合理的なんですけど
そういうのは今現代人が馬鹿にしちゃうしって言って自分たちがやってることを見るととんでもないでしょうし
これ山の信仰とかね そういうわけ
いろんなもう本当にそうではあるでしょうに
ですから このパンニャッティの世界
パンニャッティの世界といわれるこのコンベンションですね
英語で言えばね コンベンショナルというか
そういういわゆるみんなでそうしましょうという決まりだけのことで
だからある世界もないものにもいろいろ言葉で決まってあって
このパンニャっていうのを理解も本当に厳密に理解していないとヴィパッサナーの世界はうまくいかないんです
私は今日はあんまり真剣に説明してないんだけど
そこら辺は一番問題なんですからね
だから心は何種類あるかないかということよりも
このパンニャっていうの世界をちゃんと理解したならば
もう間違いはないんです
なぜかというと 瞑想する人はみんなこのパンニャってを探してるんです
幻覚を探してるんです
ないものを探してるんです
そういうことで悟りの方向へ心がいかないんです
だからしっかりした知識
智慧の人になるしか道がないんです
とにかくここで じゃあどうすればいいんですか？どうすればいいんだ？と聞いたっても
そこはもう何の意味もないんです
自分が物事あるものはあるもので
ないものはないもので確認して
そこで止まってもらわないと
子供にストーリーを言ったところで
子供は良かったと終わっちゃうでしょ
あれで十分です シンデレラのストーリー
子供に至っても で ストーリーを聞いて育てる子供たちだったら
ああ良かったと と終わっちゃうんです
そこで精神的な病気になる人々も
現代人にしておいて病気になってしまっている
あれは本当だと思っちゃうんです
あの人 実際にもうそうやってもう守り神が来て
もうちゃんと守ってくれるんだと
ひどい目に遭ったところ
行ってもうあっちこっち行って拝んだりして
ご利益をこう もう必死になって
そこはおかしいですけど
あるいは逆にヨーロッパのストーリーだから
シンデレラっていうのはね
まあもうそんなにきちんとできていると私は思ってないんだけど
やっぱりシンデレラストーリーでちょっとまあ大変危険なところもありますけどね
いわゆる自分の 苦しい状況をとんでもない夢で補ってもらっちゃうという
シンデレラシンドロームも日本の言葉ですけど
あれはね 今あまり使わないんですけどね
結構日本人にあったみたいですね
あったかどうか それは別の話で
その言葉はもう二 三年前ではね
かなり使っていたんですね
いわゆる幻覚の世界でいるということ
事実の実際にある苦しい世界は見ようと
しない心の状況 ではあの人で何言うかというと
真面目に頑張りなさいと
いい結果になるんだというぐらいの話でしょうね
結局は 夢はね  12時で終わっちゃうんだと
だからもしかするとそのストーリーは現代風に入れ替えると
もしかするとあの女の子がみんな家を出て行っちゃったんだから
一人で家で一人で寂しくて
頭でいろいろ妄想したとね
まあこのパーティーのこと
そこで自分も自動的にそこに参加しているような感じでいろいろイメージしているところで
10時になってくると
みんなもうどんどん戻ってくるんだから
寝て もうこれからまたはいどうぞいらっしゃってくださいと
また服を畳んであげたり
いろいろもうお世話しなくちゃいけないし
だからいきなり夢からね
あの 何て言いますか デイドリームと言うんですけどね
それから目が覚めたぐらいのことですけど
で 元に戻ったと そこで働き者の女の子っていうのは
誰でもお嫁にはもらいたいもんでしたからね
ですから この何も仕事をしないで食べては寝る人々よりは
一生懸命朝から晩まで仕事している人だから
服はボロボロかもしれませんだけど
どう見たっても体がよろしいし
格好いいし で 的確に働いているんだから
見る限り気持ちいいし
だから男の場合はやっぱりこの女の人だったら
問題はいちいち文句言ったりとかね
ああだこうだなくてね
わがまま言ったりすることでもなくて
また元気で頑張ってるんだから
まあ楽に楽な家庭をね
幸せな家庭を作られるんだと
と思うのは普通ですよ
だからそちらで言ってるのは
女の人っていうのは綺麗な服を着てね
ご飯食べてソファに座っていたらもうお嫁にはいけないということなんだよ
世の中で今でもその事実はそのままでしょうね
あんまりこのおしゃれとかあることなく
普通にみんなと行動して動いてる人々には
もうとても簡単にもう相手が見つかる
すごい格好つけて まあもう誰か捕まろうと思ってる人々にはもうなかなか見つからない
よ まあまあ それもごく普通な
まあですからまあそんなもんで
だから間違ってそういうストーリーなんか受け取っちゃうと違う方向に行っちゃうし
そのまま文字通りに見てみればそれだけのことです
ですから この言葉の使い方とその裏にある意味のその関係はね
気をつけなくてはならないんですね
そのこのネーミングの働きはね
ちゃんとこの瞑想の世界でも気をつけてほしいんですね
で 例えば痛みがあると
まあ痛みとネーミングするんであって
それ以上心を持っていくと
全くのくだらない世界にも妄想のもう幻覚の世界に行ってしまっちゃうんですね
で 何か自分で心で何か体の感覚をとってるんですね
その取ってる体の感覚に
それなりに痛みというだけのことで
違う言葉でもいいんです
ですから 日本人が痛みと言っても構いませんし
必ずしもアメリカ人も痛み痛みと確認する必要はないんです
アメリカ人もそういう自分たちのそれなりの言葉を使えばよろしいし
私たちは違う言葉を使っているし
でもそちらに何かの体の感覚があるんですね
その何かのその感覚は万人に同じものなんですね
その万人に同じその働きだけとって
それはあの認識をあの知る世界をずっと続かないんですよ
ラベリング言葉がないと
それで言葉という道具を持って
この認識の世界をずっと続けていくだけ
言葉に意味を探さないんですね
それから言葉のおかしいところっていうのは
あるものにもないものにも言葉はつけられますから
そこら辺また返って気をつける
言葉が例えば言葉があるんだからといって
それそのものもあるということはないんですね
そうやって 知恵の世界をまあとにかく掴まなくちゃいけない
だからそこら辺わかると
このいろんなまあ言葉
人間の間違いやら冗談やら
何でもとても簡単に使えるんです
だから まあ冗談言いたければ
世の中どんなことを見てもいくらでも言えるんです
いわゆる笑いたければ
なぜならば言葉というのは不完全だから
すごく違う意味でも取ってみることもできますね
例えば足元にご注意くださいと
ちゃんと言ってないんです
あれ ホームと電車の間が空けてますから
足元にご注意くださいと
足元に注意してると歩けないんですよ
だから落っちゃってしまいます
足元の注意したんだからといって
まあでも誰もそうやって落ちたわけじゃないんです
だからまあ何を言ってるかとわかってますからね
だから厳密に言いたければ
もうね 電車の中ですか
そこをちゃんと見て足を入れてくださいと
先を見てね そこをそれは正しい言葉の使い方のね
何のことなく足元にご注意くださいというだけで
足元にご注意と先見えませんから歩けないんです
ですから まあまあそうやってまあ言葉使ってますから
あまりとらわれてはいけませんとね
言葉 で あの 例えばこの瞑想の世界でこのチャクラがあるんだとかね
クンダリニがあって それからもうでチャクラの名前忘れてましたけどね
で 何々チャクラとかね
まあ 7つですかね  [笑い]ああいうのはなぜ物件使わないかって
それを幻覚が作って 幻覚が実際だと作ってしまえば
単なるもう幻覚が現れるだけで瞑想でなくなっちゃうんですね
で 中国人のこの何ですか
気の話も同じことなんです
体の暖かさやらね あるいはなんとなくこのビリビリビリビリと感じることやらね
それは気ですよと 気ですよと言った途端
気は別々に存在することになってしまっちゃって
すごい気功の世界が生まれてきちゃうんです
そこで人々は気を育てるためにいろいろ修行しちゃうんです
だからものすごくおかしくなってしまっちゃうんです
逆にとっちゃえば一番正しいのにね
手が温かいと 例えば手の先で何かビリビリビリビリと感じたっても
これはもうもうなんて言いますか
静電ですから 今は結構気が感じますけどね
まあ感じやすい だからどっちかとわからないです
それは静電か他のものかと
それにとらわれて またいろいろ運動して発見するんでね
こうこうやって運動して
この体の感覚をね だからこれは地球の重力によって我々生きてるんだから
この手とかゆっくり動かしたりすると
この重力に引っ張られてるでしょうね
それで体の力でまた動かしたりするでしょ
そこで差が生まれるんです
その差がもう何か動いてるように感じちゃうんですね
まあ何か勘に水を入れてこうこうやったりしてみてください
ある日 それ感じるでしょ
そこで体の動きに徹底的に集中する時でも同じことで
このいろいろ電気信号で神経が変化
神経の働きがそれ瞬間瞬間神経が変化しないと手が動かしたりはできません
それで手が動く 動かすために必要な神経信号がちゃんと行っていて
それなりに筋肉やら細胞やらね
刺激されていろんな変化を起こしたりする
その中にあるリズミカルなパターンが当然出てくるんですね
そこで集中しちゃうと意識するとその変化はちゃんと認識できるんです
だからどっちが正しいかとわからないですよね
中国の気功の話が正しいかと
私の話が正しいかと 私もわかりません
私は向こうは信じてないだけで
でも向こうが言ってる Function 働きは自分でも知ってるんです
時々そういうすごい働きもあるんだと
でもあんた言ってることじゃないんだと
例えばこのチャクラのチャクラの話ですか
したっても で 自分が集中するところによってすっごく明確に見えてくるんです
だからわざとチャクラ瞑想の場合は
この下からどんどん集中力を上まで持っていくように
もう一応プログラムして暗示かけられてるんですね
そこで意識はそういう風に持っていくんです
何もなくやった方が何が起こるかと
もっと分かりやすいんだけどね
前もってプログラム組むんじゃなくてね
中国的な瞑想で この気は体の中
いろんなところで回す方法とかあって
で 中国の世界ではもう日本も同じですけども
おへそっていうのはすごい大事なところなんですね
丹田って言うんですか
あっちは あれは魂のいるところなんですね
お腹の中だから だから食いしん坊でしょうね
で まあインド人にとってはね
まあ深層だからね 魂が宿っている場所がね
で そこでそこを中心にして意識を持っていく
だからその通りに感じちゃうんです
私はもう徹底的な懐疑主義者だから
他のいろんな方法でもやってみたんです
右足の裏から考えてみようと
何のことなく それでその通りに感じていくんですね
そうすると 丹田で始まなくても
右足の裏から始めても同じことで流れるんですね
じゃあ左足から それでできます
ある日はじゃあ頭のてっぺんから始めてみようと
夜 頭のてっぺんからエネルギーが入って
どんどんどんどん入って
体から地下に流れていくんだというふうに意識を持っていったら
なんのことはない ずっとエネルギーが流れて下へ行く
上から流れて下へ行くと
で あ ちょっと待てと じゃあもし下から上に行くと思ったらどうなるんですかと
次に ただ何のことなく
また集中力が生まれてくると
エネルギーは下からどんどんどんどん上へ上がっては出ていく
下から上へ上がっては出ていくと
じゃあそれで回ってみたらどうですか？それちょっと複雑ですけどね
まあそういう風にも瞬間はなったんですね
っていうことは 解釈次第ということなんです
だから誰の解釈を見ているんですかね
誰の解釈も認めるなということなんです
そんなものは解釈であって
パンニャッティであると
で いろんなこの瞑想の体験者のね
いろいろテキストでもね
現代的なテキストがありますからね
インドのね ヨーガとかね
ヨーガのいろんな行者たちの話とかね
いろんな人はいろんなことを体験している
だからそこは我々はそんなことはないと
あんた嘘をついているということは言わない
その人は嘘をついているわけじゃないんです
その人は実際に瞑想してそういうことを体験しているんだから
我々聞くのはだから何ですかと
ただそれだけなんです
ある人のテキストで このものすごいこの頭の真ん中
すっごい穴が開いちゃって
そこから上からすごい光が自分に入ったんだと
それはまあ本人にとってはまあなんて言いますか
それはまあ真我の体験であって
もう瞑想の終了なんですね
私に言えば あなたのそういう体験があったことは
まあまあそれはその通りですよと
だから何ですかと それだけ
あんた間違ってるんですよとかね
あんた頭が変ですよっていうことじゃないんです
間違ってるわけでもないし
頭変であるわけでもないんです
真面目に それなりに厳しく
長い間頑張ってきたんだから
そういう経験が生まれたんであって
もしその実験として 他の人に魂は頭の穴開けてくるんじゃなくて
下からドーンと来て頭から抜けて抜けていくんだとちゃんと教えてあげて瞑想させてください
その人に瞑想の能力あるならばの話で瞑想できる能力があるならば
全くその通りにその現象が起こるんです
下から上へ行くという
だから世の中いつでもこの人間っていうのは上見るという癖があるんだから
だからこの神にお祈りする人々も笑っちゃいますけど
空めっちゃ問題ない だから私はその瞬間で自分の意識は宇宙に入れたいんですね
地球にいる人々はこちらにいる人はこちらに神がいると
こちらにいる人はこちらに神がいると思って
お祈りするんだけど それは神様にお願いします
神様はどこにいればいいんですかと
だから地球は地球を見て
こちらにいる人はこちらが空でしょうし
こちらの人はこちら 空でしょうし
神様どこにいるんですかね
まあそんなもんでね 世の中っていうのはやっぱり上見る習慣があるんだから
宗教の世界ではいつでも上から精霊が降りるというね
概念がありますね ですから
それはヒンドゥーの世界でも同じことで
上から出てくるんだと
だから自由にやっちゃうと
その人の経験は同じ経験
ヨガ瞑想やってる人々の経験は
仏教の瞑想やったっても生まれるんです
ほとんど似ている で 仏教はただ科学的に見てるだけの差なんですけど
でもこちらではもう前もって暗示かけて暗示かけたり洗脳したりしないんだから
人 人の人の人の経験はそれぞれ違うんです
ですから 光見えるとしてあっても
その見える光の形やら場所やらってまた違うんです
例えば 前に見える 前に見えて
それはどんどん大きくなって自分の中に入ってくる場合もあるし
あるいは体と関係なく
なんと体の感覚って消えてしまったら
ただ単にどこもこもないんだけど
光があるという感じにもなったりする
ヴィパッサナー 本当にこの仏教の世界を理解してヴィパッサナーやってる人々に見える光は
それはもう障害であって
すぐもう30分以内でそれはもう消しておかないと
もう瞑想はもう上手く進まないんですけど
その光の見え方違うんですね
で なんとなくすごい明るいというか
変な光ではないんです
ものすごく明るいと で
全く電気ももうランプも何もない暗い部屋にいるんだけど
自分にとっては別にどうってことない
もうすごいもう明るくて
全部明るくて もう行ったり来たり
もう何でも見えたりもします
そうやって場所と関係なく見える光が
明かりがあって 本当に見えるんです
その時は別に何のことなく暗いという感じがないんです
ですから このまあ すぐそこでね
仏教の世界を知っている人々だから
これすぐもうヴィパッサナーで観察して
まあ続けますからね まあすぐなくなりますけど
引っかかったらかなりまあ残っちゃうんですけど
そこで人間欲があるんだから
それでありがたいんじゃないかと思ったりするでしょうしね
そういうことで仏教の世界から離れちゃう
ありがたくないと別にどうってことないんだというふうな感じで行かなくちゃいけないんですね
で 他の人々に他の宗教の影響とかなんとかあったならば
体の中から光が現れていくことか
外から出て光が出てくるか
そういう別な現象で見えちゃうんですね
ちゃんと外から出てくる光か中から生まれて出ていく光かというふうに区別見えちゃうんですね
いわゆる対象として 対象として明かりが出てくるんですね
主観的な対象か 客観的な対象か
そんな瞑想も全く知らない
仏教しか知らない人がやっちゃうと
対象として明かりが出てくるんじゃなくて
明るくなっただけやと
明るいと だからそうやっていろいろ差があるんですね
だからそこら辺はもう
洞窟があるっていう言葉があるんだから
洞窟そのものっていうのは感じでもあるわけじゃないんですね
ただ名前だけと ですから
このすごいこの言葉で解釈する世界にね
引っかかって引っかかって引っかかっていますけど
何にも引っかからないようにしなくちゃいけないんです
[笑い]